I can have all the technology I want in
the world, but if the people and
processes that they use are broken,
we're still going to have an impact.
Like if you look at some of the largest
breaches, right? It's a result of
somebody doing something unintentional
or because they didn't know uh like look
at, you know, things like Target, right?
Where HVAC system compromised the the
payment card industry uh payment card
information. So I when we look at these
things, a lot of it's lack of awareness
or lack of understanding of the risk
that's present. And I think that the
reason that most organizations fail in
in the security space I had, you know, I
have some peers that are excellent
leaders in the education space for
security and they the reality is if you
connect it to them and make it personal,
it becomes valuable. If I tell you, hey,
don't leave your laptop in the car or or
something that's you're like, okay,
whatever. All you care about is the
laptop. I'm going to do it anyway. But
when you start relating to like the the
risks of using things in public places
or compromise of personal data and how
it relates to their personal life or hey
we even send out stuff in my company
about hey it's holidays make sure you
lock your houses when you're going
traveling for the holidays right things
like that you get people in the mindset
of making security a part of who they
are so that they think that way it
shifts the culture in organization and
it makes it much more effective.
[Music]
Joshua Scorpino, thank you so much for
joining me for another speaker series on
the human zero day. Really excited to
have you here. H thank you for taking
the time to do this.
>> Yep. I appreciate it. Wish I could have
jumped on sooner, but I'm ready to go.
>> Well, we're going to get a lot done in a
very short amount of time, so I'm really
excited for this. Uh Joshua you your
profile really doesn't need much
introduction. I mean you've been around
the block you've seen so many things in
the context of cyber security and in AI
uh from anything like organizations like
for humanity to NIST which is really all
about you know how do we think through
the the different risks and evaluation
methodologies for assessing them and
different solutions and most recently
over the last almost three years
CISO of Trust Engine. So, so Joshua, a
lot for us to unpack. Thank you for
being here. I'm going to dive straight
in. Human security, human
vulnerabilities.
What is this thing that we start hearing
about more and more in the context of
humans, in the context of security for
organizations?
>> Well, humans are our biggest risk,
right? It's it's important to understand
that the human element in security is
something that constantly needs focus
because attack methodologies keep
shifting. And it's important for us to
understand how does that change the
dynamic with the human part of uh our
organization, right? We have to be able
to educate them. We have to be able to
make them prepared to handle the risks.
We have to ensure they have the right
tools to address the risks and that they
have the the the necessary uh the
ability to identify threats, report
those threats, and act accordingly to
ensure that we minimize risk to the
organization.
>> Okay. Okay. So, I'm hearing a lot of
responsibility on humans, which is good.
But I also know that humans tend to be
irrational creatures. We did a year of
behavioral economics. Learned that much.
And and I'm curious right before we get
into the solution space and what can we
do to help protect the vulnerabilities
of the weakest element in the chain.
Let's talk a little bit about the threat
to vectors because they have been like
you said evolving quite rapidly and
differently and the fact that humans are
are you know at the at the sort of the
the forefront of these attacks and
that's that's been around for for ages
and decades. What are you seeing today
in organizations in the context of the
risks that are actually happening and
making an impact on organizations?
>> So, so the biggest threat today is right
the onset of AI. We have AI that's a lot
it's being used by adversaries to
increasingly target organizations uh all
things from improved fishing attacks
right historically it's like look for
the bad grammar look from this below
with the onset of Chad GPT and large
language models now attackers have that
at their fingertips and they can
leverage that to improve their their
targeted attacks and ensure that what
they're doing is relevant and those
things that we would commonly tell
people to look for they're not present
anymore right uh I mean we even have I'm
I teach also in college and the problem
is in even the academic world they're
like is this written by a person or
written by a human and and the irony
behind this is as a professor like you
go on and you're like well you can't use
AI but you can put your your assignment
into a tool and then say humanize it
right so it's like we're we're at an
impass here uh and I think that the same
thing applies in the in the security
space actually one of the uh I did I sat
on a committee for a a PhD student and
he focused on training AI I models by
using AI built built content. So it was
an area of learning model that was based
off of AI generated fishing. So these
attacks are becoming increasing complex
and organizations really need to
understand how that evolves and educate
their users that the things that worked
previously to detect the threats are not
going to be the same even even getting
into uh impersonation right because
obviously that's prevalent across you
look across Hollywood now we have people
they leveraging um you know movie star
identities and impersonating them to
sell their products or something like
that and and this happens not only at
that scale but it can also happen of hey
I'm the CEO and uh I need gift cards and
they can impersonate the voice of the
CEO by a recording he posted online or
by something else. So these threats are
becoming increasingly complex and we
need to educate users that you need to
do more than your cursorary uh checks
that you're used to. You need to
understand how the risk has evolved and
you need to relate that back to their
personal life. Are you thinking
differently as a CISO in terms of the
tools that you equipped your
organization in the context of the onset
of these new threats? So is the way that
you're thinking through adopting
different types of tools from detection
and response to awareness and training
to procedures is that changing at all
during these years?
>> I wouldn't say the fundamentals are
changing. I would say that there's more
focus on understanding the risks better
because the nature let's take vendors
for example, right? Almost half the
vendors now have an AI capability. So
understanding that when we're onboarding
these vendors, do they does the AI
solution on by default? What are the
risks associated with the AI technology
using right are they or is the is the
data being retained for training on a
model on a third party service? These
are all things that need to be
considered as part of the the the
evolution of our ecosystem and our
vendor is that we manage and really
understanding the the systems that our
employees are using on a daily basis.
How is that that threat landscape
evolving? uh based on these these new
technologies being deployed. So really
it's a it's a focus on educating and
saying look new things are coming out th
this is the company's stance on how we
use these things these are the ways they
should be used these are the ways they
shouldn't be used and also with the
educating ensure that we're doing the
proper diligence on the the security and
compliance side and saying is this in
alignment with what our expectations are
as an organization and what the how the
technology should be used or what what
technology should be used and do we have
the proper controls in place to mitigate
the risk of let's a um confidential
information being overly shared, right?
Uh somebody uploading an excel of
customer information and going, "Hey,
let's sort this for me, right? That's
not acceptable." Um but then also third
party models with uh you know uh company
specific uh information that should not
be shared just for like development and
design related stuff or intellectual
property. Now I I'm curious Joshua I we
I've heard also on this series different
perspectives on the viability and the
effectiveness of viability and
effectiveness of training and awareness
to get people to be more conscientious
and to try and be human detectors for
these types of things. So, I'm hearing
on one hand that it's it doesn't sound
like you're putting too much emphasis on
technological tools to detect these new
and emerging threats potentially because
they are they don't look like machines,
they look like humans. How do you find
do you actually find the training and
awareness is an effective tool to help
mitigate the threats from an
organization's perspective?
>> Yeah. So, I I think it's a critical
foundational component of a security
program. The reality is I can I can have
a lot of technology based tools, but it
only takes one person to click on uh a a
email with malware or it only takes one
person to upload something somewhere
they shouldn't. Right? So I can have all
the technology I want in the world, but
if the people and processes that they
use are broken, we're still going to
have that impact. Like if you look at
some of the largest breaches, right,
it's a result of somebody doing
something unintentional or because they
didn't know. uh like look at you know
things like target right where HVAC
system compromised the the payment card
industry uh payment card information so
I when we look at these things a lot of
it's lack of awareness or lack of
understanding of the risk that's present
and I think that the reason that most
organizations fail in in the security
space I had you know I have some peers
that are excellent leaders in the
education space for security and they
the reality is if you connect it to them
and make it personal it becomes valuable
if I tell you, hey, don't leave your
laptop in the car or or something that's
you're like, okay, whatever. All you
care about is the laptop. I'm going to
do it anyway. But when you start
relating to like the the risks of using
things in public places or compromise of
personal data and how it relates to
their personal life or hey, we even send
out stuff in my company about hey, it's
holidays, make sure you lock your houses
when you're going traveling for the
holidays, right? Things like that. You
get people in the mindset of making
security a part of who they are so that
they think that way. It shifts the
culture in an organization and it makes
it much more effective. Our fish pone
percentage of my organization so we do
recurring tests regularly is extremely
low. The industry benchmark is around
3.1 to 3.5% for technology sectors of
companies my size. My organization is
around 1 and a half to 1.8% on a given
day uh depending on what tests we're
running. And that's because people are
aware and our reporting is through the
roof. like people report stuff and we
actually have a a a system that does AI
based uh testing which means it actually
models and changes the test based on how
often do they report are they more
likely to detect these threats if so
we'll make them more complex right so
it's important that you tailor the the
stuff to their level you ensure it's
bite-size relevant and you make it
actionable to their personal life
because if you change their culture
personally they're going to change what
they do at work too and you have to make
it a foundational component of who they
are. Change changing a person's
perspective is all you really have to
do.
>> That that that makes that makes a ton of
sense. Now are the do so do you see now
a shift in the way that training and
awareness is done on employees that is
and this space is adapt you see it
adapting to the threat landscape because
I know that you know traditional
training and awareness has been mainly
you know these pre-recorded videos and
different modules and even the fishing
campaigns were these you know big
generic mails that were sent to the
entire organization. Are you seeing a
shift there? I I think that it's
starting to I think there has to be and
I think it's important to note like
there is a natural evolution of security
threats right if I you have to make sure
that you're security training the balls
with it perfect examples with AI now
they're telling my kids that hey AI is a
risk is is not a big deal but showing
them that look somebody can take a 3se
secondond audio clip of me and develop a
whole campaign that targets you as my
son my daughter right and and exploit
you and makes you think, "Hey, it's me.
I'm in I'm hurt and I'm somewhere and
you need to come get me." Those things
are real. But until if I didn't say,
"Hey, there's a there's a check word and
there's a there's a word you need to say
or use something that only I would
know," they're not going to validate
that. But those are checkpoints that get
people thinking like there is a natural
evolution of security risks and we have
to be proactive and ensure that we're
thinking through those risks. And I and
the one benefit that humans have over
technology, right, is tact. So we have
the ability to to understand things and
decipher things more so than a computer
system does because a computer system AI
is generally based off learned model uh
development or iterative learning based
off something else, right? But it's all
based off learned information. That's
why if you put somebody's writing from,
you know, published articles 10 years
ago or 20 years ago into a system and
say, "Hey, is this AI?" some of the
published research comes back as yep
written by AI but the reality is we
didn't have large language models 20
something years ago that was writing
general published material so it's
highly improper but that's because it
was trained off of a system so I think
that the there is a critical focus that
needs to be placed on the evolution of
threats and and as a result of you know
new technology developments and I think
that it has to remain a core part of who
we are as a security org because
technology helps but technology ology is
a stop gap and it only goes so far.
There's still a human piece to the the
puzzle.
>> So, so Joshua, it sounds like you have
like really good thoughts on on the way
that you're treating employees as, you
know, they have these, you know, you do
have a lot on their shoulders and it
sounds like you're also equipping them
with the right tools to be able to to
stay alert, to remain proactive, and to
have a personalized approach to thinking
through these threats. If you had to
envision what the the best way to train
your employees in the most personalized
way in the context of organizations,
right? So not not not necessarily
consumers but in in businesses. What
would be sort of the golden ticket for
the best training that you would want to
provide your employees?
>> I think the training needs to be
relevant to what the organization goals
are. A lot of times the organizations
deploy blanket scarity training, right?
So I think you can do that as like a
stop gap. Hey, we're getting you on
boarded. Here's a blanket security
training. But I think really an ongoing
manner like our organizations, we do
quarterly bite-size training. They need
to be small. Think of think of your, you
know, your 5-year-old and they lose
interest after 5 minutes. Same with an
adult. If it's not what they do on a
daily basis, they really don't care. So,
they need to they need to have bite-size
education components that are tailored
specifically to the evolving risk
landscape. We do quarterly updates and
our our modules are usually between 1
and 5 minutes. Uh, and they're focused
on what are the current threats that
we're facing. If we see fishing starting
to, you know, increase from our baseline
expectations, we'll do some training on,
hey, do you remember where the fishing
button is? Do you remember this? And
then we'll give them targeted training
that's relevant to uh them as a person.
As I told you, we deploy things around
the holidays. It talks about holiday
safety, leaving lights off, even fire
safety, which we are a remote first
organization. So, physical presence is
not really something that we worry about
typically, but we do do it because
getting people thinking from a security
and compliance mindset in their daily
lives makes them bring it into the to
the workplace also, which for a remote
first organization, it's it's good to be
aware of what's going on around you and
know know the adversaries are out there.
or if you're at a coffee shop, right?
Don't leave your don't leave your laptop
unlocked. Things like that. Uh and we
have foundational security tools to
support support them achieving those
objectives.
>> Joshua, we covered in 15 minutes, I
think, uh almost an hour's worth of
conversation and opened up a lot of
Pandora's boxes, which will eventually
need to close, but I really appreciate
your time and and the energy you've put
into this. So, thank you so much for for
being here and sharing your perspective
on how we should be thinking through
human security. It's all about the human
and the and with the evolving threats. I
completely agree with you that the the
the most important course of action
training and awareness and and making it
personalized, making it in the context
of the organization and making it
relevant so that your employees actually
want to participate and not just to
check the box and move on. So, thank you
so much for being here.
>> Yep. Thanks for having me.